Bachelorette villain Chad Johnson may be
a nice guy after all I am still looking
for love after the Bachelorette star
ungracefully exited Jojo fletcher season
threatened his fellow suitors and did
this he made his first public appearance
on Jimmy Kimmel Live Monday showing us a
much softer side to his personality
saying the show amped up the crazy
Chad's dog pumpkin also made an
appearance lazily lounging behind him
making us question his quote villain
title even more but then he said this
about Jordan Rogers you told him that
after the show was over you were gonna
go to his house and beat him up or
something is that is that still the plan
I mean things and Kimmel confronted chat
about the photo bachelor nation is going
crazy over his Instagram pic kissing
bachelor at contestant Robbie's
ex-girlfriend why did this happen you
know I mean we were traveling and we
just happened to see each other you know
I mean you start off as weird like just
kind of friends I don't know I don't
want to make any judgments or say where
it's gonna go